von johnny depp jetzt so ilias im baarer
elias m'barek und dem ich habe es heute
morgen genannt tampon skandal den aber
nicht elias m'barek verursacht hat
sondern tatsächlich die ard denn die
versteht wenn es um tampons und das
weibliche ja die weibliche klitoris geht
scheinbar überhaupt kein spaß mehr der
gute elias im barrique der ist ja gerade
auf kinotour präsentiert seinen neuen
film liebe dings und war auch bei
verstehen sie spaß zu gast hier sehen
wir ein paar ausschnitte dort hat er
seinen neuen film präsentiert die
sendung wurde bereits im märz
aufgezeichnet jetzt ausgestrahlt und
nach unseren informationen gab es
bereits im vorfeld der aufzeichnung
mächtig unstimmigkeiten es wurde
aufgrund auf wunsch des senders der
trailer des films
umgeschnitten bzw gekürzt das problem
wie ich gerade schon angekündigt habe
tanzende tampons und das wort klitoris
ja schauen wir uns doch vielleicht die
strittige szene man an denn elias
m'barek war ja auch am freitag hier bei
bild zu gast und wir haben natürlich mit
ihnen zum beispiel über das thema
feminismus gesprochen und haben uns
nicht gescheut diese szenen zu zeigen
feminismus ein thema in dem film hallo
die haben sich als tampons verkleidet
ähnliche fruchtbarkeits den song dann
würdest du sagen dass die minister immer
immer natürlich also feminismus bedeutet
ja dass man dass man dass man dass man
für die gleichstellung von frauen mal
eintritt und dass man dass das dass man
dass man alle geschlechter sowohl mann
als frau oder auch alles andere war gut
im zeugnis muss
gleichwertig behandelt und das natürlich
bin ich dann absolut dafür müsst
noch ist
ja tampons und klitoris scheinbar zu
viel des guten für verstehen sie spaß
was elias m'barek dazu sagt das kann ich
ihn jetzt zeigen wir haben ihnen
natürlich gefragt was er dazu sagt dass
diese szenen herausgeschnitten werden
musste vor allem es wurde auch noch ein
wortbeitrag von ihm rausgeschnitten aus
der sendung wurde nämlich das wort
klitoris benutzt hat und er sagt die
entscheidung zur trader kürzung hat in
diesem fall die rede nein das ist das
falsche statement elias im barrique
gesagt was anderes ich lese ist ihnen
aber gerne vor das ist nämlich ja elias
im barrique sagt das ist in meinen augen
keine diskussion mehr für das jahr 2022
wir sollten viel mehr darüber sprechen
und viel unverkrampfter mit weiblicher
sexualität umgehen und auch generell mit
sexualität an sich dieses thema gehört
wie alle anderen auch zum leben und da
kann ich nur sagen
lieber elias du hast sowas von recht so
und jetzt kommen wir ganz schnell noch
zu dem anderen statement und zwar haben
wir natürlich auch beim sender angefragt
und der sagt dass diese kürzungen
abgestimmt waren mit der
produktionsfirma constantin
hier sehen sie das statement inhaltliche
tabus spielten dabei auch bei der
redaktionellen kürzung des talks keine
rolle das war einzig eine dramaturgische
entscheidung ja und als wäre das nicht
noch genug haben wir natürlich auch bei
der regisseurin nachgefragt ob das
eigentlich so stimmt was
das das abgesprochen war und anika
decker sagt nein wir hätten uns sehr
gefreut wenn dieser gezeigt worden wäre
also der trailer zeitgeistige themen
sollten auch bei den tv sendern
zeitgemäß beachtung finden und ich
glaube zu diesen beitrag von anika
decker der regisseurin von liebes links
habe ich nichts mehr hinzuzufügen das
unterschreibe ich zu 100 prozent